at that moment
all right hornets don't have a timeout
chance to win it right here
rozier gonna have to put something up
[Applause]
yes terry rozier
how do you
[Applause]
make do up
the officials are checking to make sure
and it's gonna count
the replay confirmed down for a decision
successful two-point field goal prior to
expression again period game
yes it does and the hornets win a game
when they were dead to rights my word
stole it
incredible has terry rozier been this
season look at this
the warriors wanted to carry he just
loses the handle
degree of difficulty off the charts
terry rozier a 20 point fourth
quarter he scores the last 10
for the hornets he almost dribbled that
off his knee
regains control
and rattles it home his eighth triple
well that's a two it doesn't matter it's
good splitting hairs partner
terry rozier 34 more points
and his first game winner as a hornet
he got popped in the chin you name it it
happened
it was worth the deal all the
frustration all the turnovers
all the the times that the lead just
slipped through the fingertips
to win it in that fashion says something
about this year's club
it does the character the guts
resiliency
that never quit i'll feel you son-in-law
[Laughter]
so the hornets continue their dominance
over the golden state warriors they have
now won